hi thanks for joining us today we're
gonna be talking about Mission Possible
moving your most sensitive data to GCP
my name is Christopher Johnson I
typically go by CJ I'm a security
product manager
I look after compliance regulated data
and what we're talking to you today
about assured workloads for government I
have with me Susan hi everyone great to
see everyone I'm Suzanne Gao I'm a
managing director at Deloitte I oversee
our global export controls practice and
focusing on regulations related to
export controls as well as sanctions and
working with CJ today on this fantastic
presentation so looking forward to it
all right well at the very base of this
we want to talk about the challenge of
compliance and cloud compliance what
we've learned over the last couple years
is a lot of the regulations a lot of the
compliance regimes that we look after
weren't written with the with cloud
computing in mind and a lot of them
reflect requirements that come from
previous world of having everything in a
single data center or in a single room
and our customers require something a
little bit more complicated than that
however as we move to this managing
compliance with multiple data security
regulations in cloud environment can be
really complex and slow especially for
government agencies this is what we've
really been thinking about and trying to
imagine solutions for this it gets extra
complicated when you have workloads that
have to comply with multiple different
compliance and export regulations
I'll let Suzanne talk a little bit more
about the cloud compliance landscape
thanks CJ so talking about the cloud
compliance landscape when it comes to
sensitive data and moving to the cloud
environment there are a lot of
regulations that you have to consider
amongst them is that's for controls as
well as cyber security and what those
really regulate are who can have access
what can be uploaded to the cloud and
then how can it be accessed so thinking
about that export controls is can be
quite stringent when it comes to
sensitive data or controlled data and so
as you can see it's restricts the
unauthorized transfer of technology and
data to non-us persons from an export
controls perspective
so there are a lot of different
mechanisms that a company can employ to
make sure that it's in compliance with
these regulations and one of them is
leaving one of the leading practices is
marking that data as controlled or not
controlled and because of the fact that
export control regulations are so
stringent a lot of other regulations can
piggyback off the various different
compliance requirements so for instance
and when it comes to cybersecurity
regulations which govern the
confidential unclassified information
and in other instances classified
information being able to employ a
program that where you're already
marking the data can also capture some
of the cybersecurity requirements as
well but certainly there are some times
that there are conflicts with these
regulations so for instance in certain
jurisdictions around the world there is
a lot of around data privacy and respect
to you nationality so if you're thinking
about from an export controls
perspective where you need to identify
who the non-us persons are there are
considerations that you have to resolve
when it comes to sharing that kind of
personal information in order to be in
compliance with the export controls and
there are different mechanisms that you
need to think about when you're trying
to determine who what and how and some
of those are through performing such
things as screening where you identify
certain parties that you can or cannot
do business with licensing which really
means is about should you need to have
provide access to a non-us person from
that perspective there are licensing
mechanisms that you can actually ask the
government for permission to do so and
then also visitor management so in the
instances that you have a physical
facility where you're needing to look at
whether it's the physical parameters of
the building or the server rooms or
whatever it might be there are there
protocols around that to control who and
who doesn't have access to those types
of physical locations and then relays
also to access control and that is from
a virtual perspective of such in the
cloud environment where it's it's
technology or as a physical access and
then with respect to disclosures just
like in cyber security if there are
instances of non-compliance there are
ways and
which you can actually disclose those
types of incidents to the government and
to resolve those sort of situations but
as you can see it's quite complex and
there are a lot of different
considerations that come into play
when it comes to compliance and moving
to a cloud environment however should
you have the right protocols in place
and of course the right tools in place
to make sure that you do monitor the who
how and what of the data and the access
of that data and the controls of that
data then it creates a smooth transition
for such for such a platform migrating
government data to the cloud is
challenging and there's a few key
questions that must be answered before
you get started and really club users
need to be confident of their answers
before they can start the migration and
pretty soon we'll get to the the
solutions to these problems but for now
let's understand a little bit more about
what it takes you have to really
understand what information will be
stored or accessed in the cloud
environment as Suzanne mentioned that
goes back to one of the fundamental
pieces of this is understanding your
information and tagging it appropriately
the next is where will that information
ultimately reside that could be
on-premise server that could be in the
cloud environment but also is really
important in terms of choosing which
regions which cloud regions your data is
stored in we'll talk here in a few
minutes a few more minutes about that
and then we also need to understand what
the process is to grant and manage
access to that information what are the
controls that are in place some of those
you get to inherit from the cloud
provider and some of those you need to
manage yourself in terms of looking
after the data making sure you have the
right controls in place that of course
feeds directly into the next question
which is who can access that data so we
put this great access control around it
now you need to make sure you're
controlling the people that have access
to the information appropriately do they
have the right attributes to access the
data in the first place
do they have the right background checks
these really important considerations
that feed into the question of who can
access that data the next question to
answer here is what is the process to
add content to the application system or
platform so we've spun up our
environment we've put all these awesome
access controls in place we have the
right people and we
to understand what it takes to move data
in and potentially out of the platform
or out of the environment once you have
things configured and working the next
one is what the encryption protocols are
and how keys are managed this one's
actually pretty exciting in one of the
areas that we really try to help our
customers out within Google Cloud and if
you're talking about US government data
it has to be FIPS 140-2 validated in
cryptography and it's really important
that you have that in place and you have
good controls around the cryptography
that's used but you also have to have a
lot of options in terms of manage the
encryption keys and then you know the
Google cloud environment you have a lot
of choices with customer manage
encryption capabilities and all of those
of course being FIPS 140-2 validated in
turn on by default and then finally how
and where are the data backups being
stored where is this information being
stored and processed this is also a key
consideration and you know some of it is
baked into the environment directly but
in other cases you need to make sure
that you're managing this yourself I
just want to add to some of the points
that CJ raised and I think these are
really critical questions when you're
thinking about migrating to a government
government data to a cloud platform is
that you can see that it really is about
multiple responsibilities and multiple
responsibility owners we're you know
thinking about what information is going
to be stored where the information is
going to be how is it gonna be accessed
and so forth and so even thinking about
our relationship you know
Lloyd's relationship with Google and
working with CJ's team that's really
been a collaboration and being able
identify and having those answers very
clearly laid out of for these various
different questions that will inevitably
create that pathway and that journey to
being able to do that migration very
smoothly so now we get to make the
transition to my favorite part here
which is you know we spend a lot of time
talking about the complexity and
challenges and the things that Google
and Deloitte are doing to make this
easier and try to help our customers
through the migration and bringing their
most valuable information to the cloud
provider so we have a new product called
assured workloads for government and
this is our solution to the problem the
idea is you're going to secure your
sensitive workload
accelerate your path to writing
compliant workloads on Google cloud
we're going to talk a lot more about
what that means and how we're going
about that
so shared workloads what is this product
basically this product allows you to
confidently secure and configure those
sensitive workloads in alignment with
the government requirements and
regulations in just a few clicks you get
to choose your compliance security
settings and we're gonna put the
necessary cloud controls in place it
doesn't mean you're off the hook
you do have shared responsibilities here
as both Susanna and I mentioned it's
really important to make sure that that
data is managed and controlled correctly
but on our side on the Google cloud side
we're making it we're streamlining that
process to configure the environment
make sure it's set up appropriately for
those compliance outcomes and getting
you started on the path towards
compliance how does this work well for
starters you log in and start using a
shared workloads this is available from
the Google cloud console which will show
you here in a few minutes and you access
the assured workloads interface this is
optimized for customers and regulated
industries and it's as simple as using
this new workload button we're using
this workload concept to put these put
this information together you set up
your new workload this is where you
configure your platform controls for
data location administrative access and
encryption again back to what we were
talking about earlier these are those
fundamental questions you have to answer
before you start moving government data
to Google cloud you have to understand
where your data is going to be stored
and processed who can access that
information and make sure that the
appropriate encryption is in place and
then finally monitor your project
details so make sure that the
environment is set up appropriately and
that you're keeping track of that
environment over time we help you with
that with the assured workloads product
so we'll talk through a little bit of
the use case here Alissa's and describe
the use case sure so a typical scenario
that we really see that I think it
really captures why something like a
quote tool like this would be really
useful is a versus an aerospace and
defense client so if you have an
aerospace and defense client if you're
familiar with that's what controls a lot
of their data is export controlled and
also from a government perspective you
know that that's sort of the key thing
and so when you're looking at the
aerospace and defense where they have
very controlled information they're
going to be so due to a lot of different
right
taury requirements when it comes to that
type of data that might potentially be
shared with other entities outside of
its organization or even within its own
organization so the scenario is the
client is already using a cloud platform
and it acquires which often many
aerospace and defense companies do they
they buy up a lot of smaller companies
and incorporate them into their IT
environment but of course with a smaller
company that might be less sophisticated
there may be some risk around the
identification of what's controlled or
not controlled on their on-prem data
that's being stored and so they would
need to then go through the exercise of
understanding what that data is and as I
mentioned before potentially having to
market to understand what's controlled
and not controlled but the client wants
to move quickly to and migrate the the
acquisition data into the cloud and also
makes sure it's showing compliance with
the various different export control
regulations as well as cybersecurity
regulations and so forth and so the
acquirer company's data is x4 controlled
so then the situation is how do they do
that quick migration into the cloud
that's already being used by the parent
company so then with that CJ you let's
talk about the 7 yeah so we're gonna
step you through this and show you a
demo of this and we're going to show you
an aerospace user that's going to create
a new workload with multiple regulatory
compliance requirements for the data
we're going to talk about storing
processing that data in the cloud and
requiring for example customer
management corruption u.s. data location
and US persons controls in terms of
support of that data so let's show you
the demo we're going to come into cloud
console and for starters we'll come over
to the menu you can see we have a new
compliance area we're gonna click in
there and this is going to take you
directly into assured workloads in this
case we can create a new workload and
view the ones that we've created I'm
gonna go ahead and create a new one here
today let's fire this up we'll call this
next demo and we're going to tie it to a
billing account
next you're going to choose the platform
controls that you'd like apply it like
to apply to the workload in this case
we've got IL 4 and c just turned on io 4
allows us to create a workload that's
compatible with aisle 4 controls
specifically it's going to limit Googler
access so Google support access to only
us persons we also have CJIs options so
you just does something very similar but
it also enables support for escorted
access to support use cases we're gonna
use aisle 4 today what happens next is
the regions that are available to me are
limited based on the compliance
framework that we've chosen in this case
IL 4 only supports us regions or us
regionality of data so only us regions
are available to me I'm going to choose
US central 1 and now I can see which GCP
services are available this will limit
the capability to the services that are
compatible with these controls both for
regionality and personnel access
controls we're gonna click Next
we're going to configure the encryption
we'll start this thing up today set the
rotation period and then click Next
we'll review the workload what you can
see here is we've worked very hard to
make this a extremely streamlined
experience for creating a new workload
putting the controls in place and
getting you ready to onboard data into
GCP i'm going to create the workload
what's going to happen here as I
mentioned in the platform we're going to
create the project both for the assured
workload as well as for CMAC so we have
some separation of duties there and
we're going to put the back-end
infrastructure and controls in place to
protect the data in a compliant fashion
we can go in here and get some details
on the project it's going to give us the
platform controls that were applied
it'll show us the controls specifically
that we're applied in this case which
are data access controls and data
residency we can see the region that was
chosen
obviously the creation time and then the
projects themselves like I said it will
create one for CMAC it will create one
for the assured workload and it will
show you the services that are in scope
for that particular workload which of
course can launch into the project and
at this point I can begin onboarding
data into the platform in a compliant
fashion
creating VMs creating workloads and
really starting to take advantage of the
platform in a compliant fashion as you
can see from the demo we've worked
really hard to make this process a
streamlined and as efficient as possible
for creating a new compliant workload
and what we've done there is we've put
those guardrails around your environment
and your infrastructure to make sure
that you can have those compliance
outcomes in the end and ultimately the
product features that we're talking
about and demonstrating here is the
automatic enforcement of those data
location constructions so in the case of
the US government compliance
requirements these have to be stored at
rest in specific US regions what we're
able to do with this product is help you
configure that so that it'll only be
stored at rest in these u.s. regions and
also make sure that your users of your
environment don't accidentally store
somewhere that they're not supposed to
so we're compliant from the beginning
and then we help you put those
guardrails in place to prevent Mis
configuration errors that could result
in a noncom non-compliant configuration
so that's the first part of it which is
the automatic enforcement of that data
location the next part is personnel
access this one's actually very
interesting what we're able to do is
limit Google personnel access based upon
predefined attributes such as
citizenship a particular geographic
location or potentially background
checks so for example the support force
Aegis allows us to have controls in
place that make sure that it's a u.s.
person accessing from a US location with
a very specific background check in
place or they're escorted by somebody
that is finally the built-in security
controls here this reduces the risk of
accidental Mis configuration by choosing
the available platform security
configurations we'll help you put those
controls in place again the idea here is
start from a compliance beginning and
then help you keep that in place as you
move through the lifecycle of your data
on GCP automatic enforcement of product
deployment location this allows you to
restrict the deployment of new resources
to specific Google Cloud regions based
upon an organizational policy next the
security and compliance monitoring we're
working on this now it's coming in q4
and this will allow you to continuously
monitor the security and compliance of
your shirt workload environment and
adjust so settings is needed based upon
your own security and risk assessment
there's also a premium support offering
here for shared workload customers this
allows you to ensure that only us person
support from us locations are available
24 by 7 to help meet compliance
requirements and this does require
additional support services purchased
though so the premium support offering
is is quite interesting thank you so
much for your time today it was a blast
getting to introduce assured workloads
for government we're really excited
about it and thank you so much for your
time Suzanne thank you so much for
helping us out with us oh it's been
great and it's been a fun time and it's
been a great journey so I really
appreciate the being able to participate
today